lockerungen in etappen wie die
bundesregierung aus dem shutdown
stufenweise raus will sanktionen gegen
russland die eu antwortet auf die
verurteilung des oppositionspolitikers
umweltkatastrophe im mittelmeer wegen
einer ölpest hat israel alle strände des
landes geschlossen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten um sieben die vom sport
hat heute ein arbeitnehmer hat einen
schönen guten abend doch von mir
mit den ersten warmen tagen wächst auch
die sehnsucht danach wieder ins normale
leben zurückzukehren
doch wie geht es weiter nach öffnung von
kitas und grundschulen heute und
friseursalons nächste woche die
kanzlerin warnt davor zu schnell zu viel
zu lockern
zumal die sieben tage incidents gerade
wieder leicht ansteigt die nächsten
öffnungs schritte sollen sorgsam
vorbereitet werden flankiert von immer
mehr impfungen und schnelltests patricia
wiedemeier kaum werden die schulen und
kitas wieder geöffnet geht die
diskussion um weitere schritte los vor
allem der bayerische ministerpräsident
rached mal wieder voran nicht nur
friseure sollen in bayern öffnen dürfen
er schlägt vor dass wir dort
pflegerische leistungen der zunehmende
den gleichen umfeld wie fußpflege und
unvergleichbares also körpernahe
dienstleistungen und dass wir an
nächster woche aus einem anderen grund
die bereiche gärtnereien gartenmärkte
und blumenläden damit rein tun weil es
handelt sich hier verderbliche ware auch
die kanzlerin schlug am morgen im cdu
präsidium einen drei stufen plan für den
ausstieg aus dem corona shutdown vor
lockerungen wären in folgenden bereichen
denkbar bei persönlichen kontakten in
schulen und berufsschulen beim sport in
restaurants in der kultur jetzt geht es
darum ein konzept zu haben für diese
ersten öffnungen und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass bis zur nächsten mpk
man sich dort geeinigt hat gleichzeitig
zeigt die regierung sich besorgt darüber
dass die infektionszahlen derzeit wieder
ansteigen die gute entwicklung sei
vorbei und die bisher geplanten
öffnungen seien ja schon ein erhebliches
mehr an übertragungs risiken
das ziel der bundesregierung ist was wir
aufmachen das wollen wir dann auch
durchhalten lockerungen die man wieder
zurücknehmen muss und auf die
schließungen folgen
das kann niemand wollen auch die
diskussion um die impfstrategie und um
impf prioritäten geht weiter schon am
morgen hatte die familienministerin
dafür geworben das personal von grund-
und förderschulen sowie kitas bei der
impfung vorzuziehen
ich bin dafür
wir dort mit mobilen impf teams arbeiten
die in die kitas in die schulen kommen
dadurch könnte das ganze viel
effizienter auch laufen viel schneller
gehen
der entwurf für eine geänderte
prioritätenliste ist heute mit den
ländern abgestimmt worden am mittwoch
schon könnte diese in kraft treten
wer die erwartungen vor dem nächsten
bund-länder-treffen am dritten märz in
großer kulturmanager in berlin ist denn
da schon mit einem konkreten öffnungs
plan zu rechnen
also der druck ist zumindest ganz
erheblich weil sich bund und länder ja
eigentlich schon für das letzte treffen
einen stufenplan fest vorgenommen hatten
und ihnen dann nicht geliefert haben
umso höher sind die erwartungen eben
jetzt an das nächste treffen in der
kommenden woche allerdings muss man auch
sagen aktuell sind hier in berlin und
auch in den bundesländern die sorgen
wirklich sehr groß angesichts der
mutante und man spürt auch eine
erhebliche unsicherheit bei der frage
wie wird sich die werden sich die
mutanten weiter ausbreiten wird man das
eindämmen können angesichts der schule
öffnungen die wir jetzt gesehen haben
zehn von 16 bundesländern machen wieder
verstärkt schulen auf und bisher hieß es
immer man braucht zehn bis 14 tage bis
man wirklich erkennen kann wie sich
solche großen eröffnungs schritte auf
das infektionsgeschehen auswirken da der
zeitraum bis zur nächsten
bis zum nächsten treffen von bund und
ländern der ist länger das heißt also
sie müssen in der kommenden woche
möglicherweise auf einer unsicheren
datenbasis entscheiden am ehesten ist
also damit zu rechnen dass es einen
stufenplan ohne zeitliche perspektive ob
perspektive ohne feste termine für
öffnungen gibt und den plan dazu den
müssen jetzt bundeskanzleramtes chef
brown und die chefs der staatskanzleien
erarbeiten bis nächste woche
wir sind und bleiben gespannt dankeschön
the energy nach berlin
beim blick auf die korona zahlen wird
immer deutlicher der trend der rasch
sinkenden infektionsraten ist gebrochen
am wochenende waren die zahlen ja
deutlich gestiegen die bundesweite
incidents liegt heute bei 61 und aktuell
meldet das robert-koch-institut 4369
neuansteckungen das sind nur 57 weniger
als vergangenen montag 62 todesfälle
kamen in verbindung mit dem virus hinzu
das ist die aktuelle situation in der
viele länder umsetzen was sie vor knapp
zwei wochen beschlossen haben die
jüngsten werden seit heute wieder im
klassenzimmer unterrichtet nach sachsen
und niedersachsen haben zehn weitere
länder die grundschulen geöffnet viele
setzen auf wechselmodell also kleinere
gruppen in der schule während andere
daheim aufgaben lösen wie das
wiedersehen der schülerinnen und schüler
in schleswig-holstein gelaufen ist hat
sich hannah hebestreit angeschaut
mit reichlich energie kommen die kinder
der kita fritz reuter grundschule zurück
in den unterricht nach wochenlangem
homeschooling atmen auch die eltern auf
wird abgenommen natürlich auch ein
bisschen bedenken sowie geht dass ihr
zweiter sohn bisschen ungewiss aber an
sich sehr froh für die kinder in
insgesamt zehn bundesländern ist für die
jüngsten am morgen die große corona
pause zu ende gegangen
hier in kiel im regelunterricht für die
ganze klasse
ich freue mich einfach dass ich mal eine
lernen müssen
ich wollte habe ich zwei oder drei
wochen in eine notbetreuung dass man
julia hans erklärt den präsenzunterricht
22 kindern die deutsche grammatik trotz
masken und freude über das wiedersehen
ein wenig sorge bleibt irgendwie ist es
ein mulmiges gefühl tatsächlich gerade
jetzt steigen die zahlen wieder wo man
sich sagt ja ist das jetzt der richtige
zeitpunkt da einzusteigen nennen weiß
ich auch nicht um den lehrern etwas
angst zu nehmen bietet
schleswig-holstein jedem schul
beschäftigten pro woche zwei kostenlose
corona tests wir sind hier natürlich mit
den kindern an der front sache ich mache
also von daher ist natürlich das schon
schön wenn die lehrkräfte aber eben auch
die anderen menschen die ich sag mal mit
anderen menschen zu tun haben und
schnellstmöglichst geimpft werden
noch aber mangelt es an ausreichend
impfstoff um allen die sich um kinder
kümmern ein schnelles impfangebot machen
zu können
wie groß ist die gefahr sich im
klassenraum anzustecken das haben
forscher der tu berlin berechnet in
unserer zdf heute app finden sie die
verschiedenen szenarien von halber
auslastung und masken pflicht bis zur
voll besetzten klasse ohne masken mehr
als 120 tausend tote und aktuell der
dritte hatte lockte und corona hat die
briten besonders schwer getroffen mit
einer art fahrplan zur normalität macht
ihnen prämie johnson jetzt hoffnung
das scheint gewagt denn die inzidenz
liegt derzeit bei 124 also gut doppelt
so hoch wie bei uns aber der trend ist
stark fallend wohl auch wegen des hohen
tempos beim impfen
jeder dritte erwachsene hat die erste
spritze schon bekommen
diana zimmermann berichtet auch in
england gilt die schulen zuerst trotz
kritik von lehrern und wissenschaftlern
will boris johnson am 8 märz alle zehn
millionen schüler in ihre klar
räume zurückschicken der premier
präsentierte heute seine einbahnstraße
in die freiheit weniger poetisch einen
stufenplan aus dem lokal
es gibt keinen glaubwürdigen weg zu null
witt oder eine welt ohne cupid wir
können aber nicht auf ewig bei
restriktionen bleiben die unsere
wirtschaft schädigen unsere physische
und mentale gesundheit verletzung gehen
ab ende märz dürfen sich kleine gruppen
wieder draußen treffen er ist im april
öffnen geschäfte im mai die gastronomie
das alles geht nur so machte johnson
klar wenn die infektions und todeszahlen
weiter so rapide fallen wie in den
letzten wochen
bislang war das vor allem dem lockdown
zu verdanken immer größer aber ist der
einfluss der impfungen
das belegen heute noch nicht
abschließend geprüfte studien aus
schottland wer mit einer dosis
astrazeneca oder geimpft wurde sei nach
vier wochen so gut geschützt dass eine
behandlung im krankenhaus mit rund 90
prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit vermieden
werden könne
das impfprogramm zeigt klare wirkung
neue daten besagen dass die impfungen
auch die übertragung des virus um zwei
drittel reduzieren
die regierung sieht ihre methode die
zweitimpfung auf bis zu zwölf wochen
hinauszuzögern bestätigt der
unkonventionelle ansatz hat dazu geführt
dass heute jeder dritte erwachsene brite
geimpft ist bis ende juli sollen alle
ein angebot bekommen haben das bislang
übrigens 85 prozent der briten meist
dankbar wahrnehmen
in den vergangenen wochen machten in
deutschland sogenannte impft drängler
schlagzeilen
im fall des oberbürgermeisters von halle
wiegand ermittelt jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft
sie ließ räume der stadtverwaltung
durchsuchen wegen des verdachts der
veruntreuung unterschlagung die
begründung der korona impfstoff gehören
nicht dem oberbürgermeister sondern sei
ihm nur anvertraut wiegand wies die
vorwürfe heute zurück zuvor hatte er
eingeräumt dass er und weitere
kommunalpolitiker geimpft worden sein
mit dosen die übriggeblieben waren diese
entscheidung aus brüssel war erwartet
worden und sie dürfte die ohnehin
frostigen beziehungen zu russland weiter
abkühlen lassen
die eu-außenminister beschließen neue
sanktionen gegen moskau wegen der
inhaftierung des kremlkritikers alexei
navalny gleichzeitig möchte die eu den
dialog mit russland nicht abreißen
lassen
stefan leifert aus brüssel dies ist das
bild das die eu so nicht stehen lassen
will nach der verurteilung von
kremlkritiker navalny zu zweieinhalb
jahren straflager wollen die
eu-außenminister nun ein zeichen aus
brüssel senden und sind sich einig dass
wir nicht bereit sind gewisse dinge
tatenlos zu akzeptieren und das ist so
beim feiner wein jedes ist die
vergiftung es ist die verurteilung von
ihnen einem fragwürdigen
rechtsstaatlichen verfahren nach den
kriterien die die russischen und was er
selber dafür anlegt und dazu will die
europäische union nicht schweigen
so schnell die einigung zu übersichtlich
ihr inhalt vier personen haben die
aussenminister ausgemacht die für
inhaftierung und verurteilung navalny
verantwortlich sein sollen
gegen sie soll der eu außenbeauftragte
nun ein reiseverbote und kontosperrungen
einleiten
dieses es gibt die von allen geteilter
auffassung unter den mitgliedsstaaten
dass russland immer mehr in richtung
eines autoritären staates driftet und
sich immer weiter von europa entfernt
bei seinem moskau besuch bekam der
außenbeauftragte gerade zu spüren wie
feindselig das verhältnis zwischen eu
und russland gerade ist zumindest
indirekt gesagt dass russland daran
denkt die beziehungen zur europäischen
union abzubrechen
das ist erstaunlich dass hatte russland
noch nie gesagt das verhältnis zwischen
eu und russland hat mal wieder einen
tiefpunkt erreicht zumindest in dieser
einschätzung dürften sich beide seiten
einig sein
auch gegen das militärregime in myanmar
wird die eu sanktionen verhängen
man werde sich das nicht länger tatenlos
ansehen so außenminister maß und meint
damit vor allem das gewaltsame vorgehen
gegen friedliche demonstranten
auch heute waren wieder hunderttausende
im ganzen land auf der straße und
millionen folgten dem aufruf zum
generalstreik norm unter das sind massen
wie man kaum zählen kann
vielleicht mehr als je zuvor auf den
straßen londons myanmars größter stadt
und auch aus anderen landesteilen wird
enorme zulauf für die proteste gemeldet
sie kommen allen warnungen und drohungen
zum trotz im staatsfernsehen verließ der
sprecher wort für wort die botschafter
generelle beschuldigt die demonstranten
verteidigt die soldaten und dann kommt
punkt nummer fünf die protestler stiften
die bevölkerung an insbesondere
emotionale teenager und jugendliche auf
dem pfad der konfrontation zu gehen
sie werden dort ihr leben verlieren drei
tote bisher immer brutaler gingen die
sicherheitskräfte zuletzt vor auf
wasserwerfer folgte tränengas auf
gummigeschosse scharfe munition was
abschrecken soll wie gilt jedoch auch
zum generalstreik haben sie heute
das gab es seit 33 jahren nicht wir
müssen zusammenstehen das schulden wir
denjenigen die ihr leben für uns
geopfert haben wir schließen heute
unsere geschäfte machen alles dicht und
gehen auf die straße gegen die
militärdiktatur
wenn ich heute kein geld verdienen was
bedeutet das schon aber wenn wir unter
der knute des militärs leben müssen dann
sind wir sklaven und das wollen wir
nicht mehr so gut organisiert ist dieser
protest das feld auf und überrascht wohl
auch das regime
exakt drei wochen nach dem putsch stehen
sich beide seiten unversöhnlich
gegenüber mit jedem neuen tag scheint es
schwieriger diese enorme spannung zu
lösen jedenfalls wenn es dabei friedlich
zugehen soll
für donald trump ist es eine schwere
juristische niederlage der oberste
gerichtshof entschied heute der
ehemalige us-präsident muss seine steuer
unterlagen aus den jahren 2011 bis 2018
der new yorker staatsanwaltschaft
übergeben anders als seine vorgänger
hatte trump sich während seiner amtszeit
als us-präsident stets geweigert seine
steuererklärungen zu veröffentlichen
die behörden in israel sprechen von
einer der schlimmsten umweltkatastrophen
in der geschichte des landes
es geht um eine gewaltige
ölverschmutzung israel hat alle strände
entlang der mittelmeerküste gesperrt
soldaten und freiwillige versuchen große
mengen der weg zu schaffen viele tiere
sind bereits gestorben
wo genau das öl her kommt ist unklar
michael beverungen
spätestens als der kadaver dieses jungen
finn war als letzte woche am strand lag
wurde das ausmaß der katastrophe
offenbar tee und ölklumpen an den
stränden entlang der gesamten mittelmeer
küste israels von nord bis süd überall
versuchen freiwillige fieberhaft den
strand zu säubern
einige mussten daraufhin mit
vergiftungserscheinungen ins krankenhaus
noch schlimmer hat es die tierwelt
getroffen wie diese jungs schildkröte
das ist eine braun schildkröte die wir
im süden am palmenstrand gefunden haben
völlig mit er verschmiert wir können nur
versuchen sie davon zu befreien
über die ursache gibt es bisher nur
spekulationen ein oder mehrere schiffe
sollen im winter strom letzte woche öl
verloren haben vielleicht sogar mit
absicht präsident ritalin zeigt sich bei
einer ortsbegehung entsetzt dass
schwarze dass sich hier in unseren augen
spiegelt wird zum schwarz in unseren
herzen das muss ein weckruf für uns alle
sagt für unmut nicht nur bei
umweltverbänden sorgt eine zensur die
über die ermittlungen verhängt wurde
unabhängig von deren ergebnis drängt die
zeit noch ist es kühl bei steigenden
temperaturen droht sich der teer
aufzulösen
ja ganz anderes thema jetzt zur
fußball-champions-league
da muss morgen bayern münchen in rom hat
das achtelfinal-hinspiel gegen lazio
über das erste aufeinandertreffen beider
mannschaften in der königsklasse für die
bayern der nächste schritt auf dem weg
zur titelverteidigung allerdings bei
augenblickliche formschwäche und
personalsorgen
die ewige stadt empfängt die in der
bundesliga strauchelnden münchner zur
wiedergutmachung in der königsklasse
leiten keiner der der irgendwelche
ausreden sucht sondern
stimmt schon dass es jetzt wenn
natürlich die champions league beginnt
dass wir da einfach gucken müssen das
war da aber möglichst in topform sind
das aber waren die bayern in der
vergangenen woche sogar nicht
punkteteilung mittelfeld niederlage in
frankfurt
einzig die brillante vorarbeit von der
us-armee zum 26
saison treffer von robert lewandowski
erinnerte an bessere zeiten
denn lewandowski war hier auch schon
2014 als torschütze beim 7 2 1 der
bayern gegen lazio stadt rivalen as rom
dabei so etwas nennt man dann wohl ein
gutes omen
ex fußball nationalspieler christoph
metzelder muss ich ab ende april vor
gericht verantworten
die anklage wirft ihm vor mehreren
frauen kinder und jugendpornografische
bilder zugeschickt und auch solche
bilder besessen zu haben
metzelder bestreitet die vorwürfe ein
bündnis aus sport kultur und
wissenschaft hat heute eine studie zur
publikums besuchen von veranstaltungen
vorgelegt einen drei stufen plan mit
hygiene konzepten und strategien soll
die schrittweise rückkehr von zuschauern
ermöglichen endlich wieder mitfiebern
und den emotionen freien lauf lassen
lange lange ist das her stattdessen
lehre und tristesse in den hallen und
stadien keine zuschauer zugelassen
millionenverluste für die vereine die
studie ein modulares konzept zeigt dabei
wege auf unter welchen voraussetzungen
wie der veranstaltung mit fans möglich
sein sollen
wir hoffen uns von diesem konzept als
aktives angebot der veranstalter die
damit der mediziner an die politik dass
kompetente entscheidung getroffen werden
aus dem loch dauer auszusteigen und
schrittweise wieder in eine normalität
zurückzukommen hierfür bieten wir
lösungsansätze
der leitfaden unterteilt dabei drei
bereich mit verschiedenen zuschauer
kapazitäten abstand und hygienemaßnahmen
ffw zwei masken personenbezogene tickets
um schnelltest die konzeption ein
aufbruchssignal und türöffner für den
sport der ball liegt nun bei der politik
und dem wann der umsetzung
das war mir danken zum schluss haben wir
noch etwas aus dem land der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten
da ist in san francisco ein ganzes haus
umgezogen weil auf seinem grundstück ab
gebaut werden sollen der besitzer ließ
die viktorianische holz villa 140 jahre
alt auf einen sattelschlepper heben und
an ihren neuen standort ein paar blocks
weiter bringen die kosten inklusive
amtlicher genehmigungen 400.000 dollar
das scheint sie wert zu sein die villa
die temperaturen sind oft schon
frühlingshaft auch wenn die sonne nicht
überall strahlt woran das liegt erklärt
uns gleich katja honnefer so viel von
uns danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie mit dem
heute-journal zur gewohnten zeit um 21
uhr 45
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 19 uhr einen recht schönen
montagabend menschen wie
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
war ja wirklich ein tolles
frühlingswochenende und der satellit sei
nur wenige wolken
allerdings erkannte er gestern schon
dieses bibel fällt hier an der donau und
er erkannte auch das nebelmeer in
tschechien begrenzt durch erzgebirge
oberpfälzer und bayerischen wald
sie sehen auch sehr schön den sahara
staub über dem westlichen mittelmeer und
der erreichte heute dann auch
deutschland im westen
sie sehen weitere nebelfelder die sich
zum teil c hielten dann lagen dort die
temperaturen kaum über null grad derweil
uns hamburg heute nachmittag 21,1 grad
meldete diese hohen wolken die ziehen in
der nacht weiter in richtung nordosten
völlig ausgeschlossen ist es nicht dass
da auch mal einen tropfen regen fällt im
osten ist es meist klar und am main oder
auch an der donau bildet sich wieder
nebel und die temperaturen sinken unter
klarem sternenhimmel auf plus 3 bis
minus 3 grad im westen bleibt es milder
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 11 grad in nordfriesland und 20
grad am rhein oder auch an der elbe und
es scheint häufig die sonne
wenn nicht gerade niebel stört
norddeutschland sind die wolken etwas
dichter regen werden sie aber so gut wie
gar nicht bringen und an diesem wetter
ändert sich auch mit wochen donnerstag
wenig bei temperaturen von acht bis 20
grad ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend